hey guys and welcome to Souls news today
is a short episode where you'll learn
about the most likely PC release date
for Dark Souls 2 as well as the bonus
weapons you'll get if you preorder the
game and you're gonna have to make a
choice in this video do you listen to me
talk or do you run the risk of missing
out on a copy of the limited black armor
edition of Dark Souls 2 times ticking
because I don't want to alarm you but if
you don't pre-order now you run the risk
of not getting a copy of the black armor
Edition because they're actually running
out of stock so seriously go get it bike
right now why you still watching this
video links to all the different
retailers selling it are in the
description but if you're following this
channel I mean truly it wanted on day
one right imagine missing out and all
that Dark Souls and day one is the best
invading being invaded leaving messages
all for people who are playing the game
for the first time just like you so
let's talk about why you should
pre-order on day one apart from what I
just mentioned and one big reason to
preorder was announced today so let's
talk about it because it's interesting
and it's really good news the weapons on
screen are what you get on day one if
you preorder the black armor edition the
black armor Edition also contains the
metal case the game disk enter the
official soundtrack now again links to
this urn in the description for
different retailers and the region
you're in what we didn't know until
today though is that by pre-ordering the
black armor Edition you get early access
to the weapons seen on screen and here's
the keywords early access not exclusive
access but early access so it seems like
these weapons will be available further
within the game for the people who
didn't pre-order so no one is missing
out on content by pre-ordering though
you'll probably start with these weapons
and they could essentially make the game
a bit easier or at least give you a bit
of weapon variety at the start of your
game now these weapon descriptions
detail where their assumedly found later
in the game world and these corrupted
weapons relate to the environments were
going to see and this is the right way
to do pre-order content I understand why
developers and publishers want to make
pre-order content because it's fair
marketing but when you lock away a vital
experience or an item behind a pre-order
paywall it's really something you should
support games should only be pre-ordered
from companies you trust and from has
proven themselves to be nothing but
trustworthy again
again Dark Souls two's release date on
PC has been up in the air for a while
with neither from software or Namco
Bandai willing to commit to a date and
this is common for PC releases and
especially Dark Souls since the devs are
keen to do PC correctly this time around
but as discovered by a YouTube user
named foxy o games Dark Souls has a PC
release date on from software's official
website for the title if you can read
Japanese or not you'll see that the game
is slated for a release sometime in
March however we've yet to see official
confirmation from Namco Bandai so I'll
update this video when this happens I
wish I could give you a more concrete
answer since a lot of people have been
asking but I think the answer to this
question is still when it's ready
there's a tentative May 31st date given
on Amazon and I think I'd say that's the
very latest we'll see it anyway that
does it for me goes if you want to see
more check out my channel and I'll catch
you guys next time Dark Souls 2 is in
its final stages of development with
less than a month until release I got
the chance to play hours of the full
build at the Namco Bandai office and the
game isn't just good it's incredible I
know I'm biased but I know what I want
to see in a sequel and every design
decision they've made so far impresses
me on some level this is everything I
think you would like to know let me
clarify in this video I'll be admiring
the first few hours of the gameplay
design and how I felt when I was first
dropped into the world and that's
probably one of the most important
experiences to nail down in a game